hi Bill Nye the Science Guy here CEO of
the Planetary Society and I welcome to
new media rockstars and if I understand
this I'm being featured as a rock star
first of all let me say I didn't make
that video I mean I appear but I did pop
put her on the web brain with that said
science and religion can coexist it's
not an issue for me my issue is claiming
that the world is 6,000 years old or
10,000 years old people want to use
funds tax dollars intended for science
education to teach this idea of the
earth being 6,000 years old as an
alternative to bonafide geology that
that's a misuse of my tax dollars of
everyone's tax dollars but I'm not
further to claim that if we allow this
to happen as a society as voters
taxpayers we are going to lose jobs jobs
world is the worship word this fall in
the election the United States will have
produced fewer scientifically literate
students who go on to be scientists and
engineers or managers of scientists and
engineers or people who account do the
money for scientists and engineers
venture capitalists all these things we
will fall behind other countries who do
not allow this sort of inanity now judge
Johnny Jones Dover Pennsylvania in a
judgment associated with a school board
ruling in the state of Pennsylvania
called a breath-taking inanity this
argument in other words it was so silly
the turkish breath away and how what a
waste of time it was and so i also
claimed no other developed country has
this big a population of people who are
insisting on us the earth is not 6,000
years all of us not it's not 10,000
years old and it's very much analogous
to other times in human history people
had a model of the sun going around on
the earth a mathematical model and that
was quite successful i remind everybody
the guy who invented modern astrology
totally produced a table of seaports in
the mediterranean that you could reckon
by hours and fractions of hours which
you could navigate in the mediterranean
using the sun so his mathematical model
was extraordinary it was good but as
people tried to solve more and more
problems of astronomy especially the
famous
motion of Mars as observed from the
earth where it seems instead of going
this way against the background stars it
seems to go that way for a while and
then back this way when people went to
solve that problem they discovered the
famous guys Copernicus discovered that
the earth goes around the Sun and that's
a much better model and that Nadja of
spacecraft in pictures from space is
obvious yes Clark but I couldn't be
couldn't be more clear so by analogy I'm
sure there were people who once about
the earth was flat as a working
hypothesis and then they realize it's
not people supposed that the bones of
ancient dinosaurs and other more recent
creatures say a million years ago
instead of at 65 million years ago
they thought well those creatures must
still be around we just haven't seen
them yet it travels enough to see but
that turns out to be wrong no the
ancient dinosaurs did not live at the
same time people know it's not right so
you can study that in school philosophy
class history of science class
understanding the scientific method
but it's not suitable to teach that as
an alternative to the provable geology
the provable planetary science I mean
who would want to that's what I
understood who wants to ignore the way
the whole world is that's it's a
remarkable circumstance I have so far I
love the Internet Rockstar who wouldn't
I
the modern word is monetizing that I
have found that when I go into it for
example Starbucks the price of a soy
latte it's pretty much the same whether
or not you're in new media rockstar
doesn't seem to affect the cost of the
drink which is appropriate oh very
similar very much the same I would say
one difference I'm of an age where we
used to have a video team if you in a
role gonna graphics or animation go by
you wait for the team to be rewound but
now it's almost instant with that said
it wasn't that much different it was
kind of exactly the same yeah the
animation of spiders jumping we had an
animation of bacteria growing but it was
very much like doing any other
television show except I'm sure you
realize that cameras were getting more
and more compact you can get a lot more
stuff in the same space while we're
close
well we at the Planetary Society this is
what we do we advocate for space
exploration especially planetary space
exploration we acknowledge that cuts
have to be made to balance the federal
budget here in the United States with
that said I claim we argue that
planetary science is what NASA does best
nobody else can land a rover on Mars
there's nobody others Space Agency's the
Russian space agency include the Soviets
position so for 21 at Mars Europe is
over one at Mars depending how do you
reckon the US could you could say it's
six for seven or is something like 24 21
depending how you count but landing on
Mars is quite different difficult than
we do not want to lose that capability
there are two questions that trouble us
all
since we're little kids from the time of
our youth where did we come from and are
we alone and those two questions drive
us all our whole life whatever most
wanted are there aliens is there
somebody else out there or we do is this
the only place that there's life in the
universe and where did it all start we
discovered the Big Bang but what was
before that is that even a meaningful
question was there something before the
Big Bang is this the only universe could
there be another than all these
questions if you want to answer them you
have to explore space and you have to
explore space generally beyond low-earth
orbit deep space and this is a bargain
300 millions we have nine million in a
year talking about Starbucks I mean
that's one cup of coffee per person
that's it and we fund the whole thing
and so there's a lot of competing
interests but
planetary science earned about planetary
science funding and we not waste a few
budget cuts but we think Planetary
Sciences greatest value invest you could
join us at the Planetary Society we give
you a voice in the US Congress US
administration we have a lot of numbers
I sent some letters to guys in Denmark
Japan Germany these are people who don't
live in the u.s. who are concerned about
funding for NASA and as the guy from
Argentina said if I don't have you guys
who I have if I might advance of who we
have in space and so we have the
European Space Agency and so on but NASA
it spends three times as much as anybody
so they are significant so easily if you
want to do something about it if you
want to preserve space exploration I ask
you join the Planetary Society
what Ontario dot org and I said
sometimes space brings out the best in
us it raises everybody's expectations in
our society of what's possible everybody
believes of course we can do this
because we've already been to the moon
or we've already got it's over over on
Mars with a plutonium battery taking
super sharp pictures discovering
sedimentary rocks rocks that were once
wet on the surface of Mars these these
missions make everybody expect more and
do more technically which raises the
economy for the United States and for
everybody
there's European instruments all over
the Curiosity rover it's a worldwide
effort it's a great thing well whenever
you can when it comes to fox news about
a climate change amen remember you can
get on the inside I say go for it
I mean people I meet a lot of people who
had don't respect Fox News but they have
a huge audience and I believe there are
people within the fox news organization
that quite concerned about climate
change and that's why they had me on
that's that's anecdotal I can't prove
that but it just seems to be what's
going on then I think for many
conservative people it's really
difficult to imagine that humans could
change the climate of the planet
I think all the time about the Senator
Inhofe from Oklahoma who grew up in
Oklahoma and I've spent time in Oklahoma
I must say wonderful time in our long
and your neighbors of kilometres away
miles away and I can I can see where a
guy like that literally can't imagine
that humans could change the climate of
the planet but I always call attention
to the pictures taken from space where
you see the atmosphere of the earth it's
just barely there the atmosphere it's
just barely visible it is as Carl Sagan
and others before it sentences it's like
a layer of varnish on a classroom globe
it's so thin if you could drive straight
up at highway speeds you'd be in outer
space in an hour a half if that
you have the means to do that so when I
was born there were some 1 over 2
billion people in the world I went to
the World's Fair of 1965 where the
population change to 3 billion you all
were around last year that changed to 7
so it's more than double than my
lifetime
let alone my grandmother's lifetime what
my great-grandmother it's going from a
billion and a half to seven billion in
less than about a century that's why
we're changing the world just there's
that many people and the atmosphere is
that thin that's the point I try to make
and as far as Fox News goes I'll go on
any time they'll have me
because I think it's a very important
point to make and as I said I believe
there are people within the Fox News
organization who are concerned to more
its to more nuts three earths we don't
have that so we have to find ways not to
do less that's that's an idea I grew up
with it that's traditional
environmentalism again use less clean
water wear dirty clothes
don't drive don't do this don't do that
again
but that's not very popular a lot of
people in the developing world who want
to live the way people to develop the
world with now what we need is not just
ways to do less we need ways to do more
with less and that's where I want the
young engineers of today to change the
world
so we'll see we'll see
oh well there's a couple really
difficult things right now and nobody
very few people stay in space longer
than six months because that we have
problems with bone loss even people that
work out all day several hours a day
running - no we're riding bicycles to
nowhere
it's not enough garetty don't maintain
their overall health then the other so I
always tell people I tell engineering
students we need something that spins to
create artificial gravity and those
those calculations are fundamental
physics and they're big fun and then go
back you've seen a movie that stands the
test of time 2001 Space Odyssey get
something that big and create rabbit but
maybe to go to Mars we'll do some tests
instead like astronauts in space suits
instead of breathing a full one you are
the spirit first 14.7 pounds per square
inch of fabric they breathe a
substantial fraction of that for psi
maybe there be a maybe there's some
intermediate gravity number acceleration
where you don't need 1g maybe 40% of
okay then the other thing is radiation
radiation and deep space apparently it's
troublesome if you stop there long
enough that will kill you or disrupt
enough of your DNA
I said then how do people do when
they're in that can find a gizmo for
that many months or years at a time
I mean Shackleton the guy who went to
the Antarctic had some people go crazy
on this Crump
now they had some food issues but what
if something like that goes wrong an
additional arm and then the other thing
really maybe the biggest question is
who's gonna pay for it I mean it's a
very expensive thing however getting
people to go I don't think would be an
issue I think you'd have a line around
the block if you had I spent a lot of
time with it yeah it was a thing to do
my parents were both very good dancers
and there was something important to
them there was always music playing in
house and if you like doing dancing
dancing is better so I spent a lot
during ballroom dancing and whoever used
that comet ballroom dancing if it's the
same picture we were doing what nowadays
is called the East Coast Swing so a
swing dancing and now I spent a lot of
time learning the Lindy Hop which is it
it bigger in the Venn diagram of swing
dancing East Coast would be absorbed
would be part of the Great Circle and
two men I see you're all the whole crew
there is a man you had a woman here
she's
working I cannot say enough good things
you walk up to a woman you don't even
know she doesn't know you and she
expects you to hold her in the specified
what it's the greatest I can't say it
enough good thing the other thing I'll
say objectively about swing music it's
just really good okay I I can see where
my parents just rolled their eyes I mean
when rock and roll was created a minute
the important work of Sid Vicious and
the Sex Pistols yes
swing music is really good and when you
dance to a swing song with a good
partner it is it is a joy it is it just
a joy it's something to celebrate if
you're in able bodied person able to do
that it is a fantastic thing well I
always tell people and you everybody
says this study started in school and
I'm not kidding study science to school
and then learn to write embrace language
arts they're what this is when you end
up and you will end afraid you'll do
some right and the other thing that's
come to my attention last year or so is
the importance of algebra so algebra
turns out to be the single most reliable
indicator of whether or not you pursue a
career in the math and science
engineering and it's not it's not clear
why except it seems to be that people
who don't embrace algebra don't murder
have trouble or reluctant to think extra
all sorts of things so my proposal is to
the world algebra is not expensive to
teach
we don't need exotic lab equipment and
crazy things to teach out I think in my
opinion would love to see this tested we
just start sooner start having symbols
represent numbers when you're younger
fifth grade fourth grade rather than
waiting to seventh grade and I think
this is a pretty solid problem the tests
have to be run the petticoat people love
to second-guess teachers and stuff like
that I would tell everybody I remind
everybody I learned to do algebra by
discipline by doing it over and over and
yes it was troublesome for me too
yes you have to put in the hours and
word problems we were mixing the 30%
with the 20%
trying to get the 25% of 28% how many
leaders yes I know I know how many how
many meters offense to Sparta Brown need
to keep his happy piggies contained and
then say yeah I know we all had to do it
and it's worth it it's worth
bowties you get from everywhere and my
advice if you're a bowtie wear bowtie
probably lives when you see one you like
you just gotta get don't wait because
the ones you like somebody else will buy
them well you're why you're off thinking
about why during the other part of the
store thinking about well I'll come back
tomorrow
I'll give you the 24 hour test and the
ones that that are okay I just don't get
those get the ones that you think
they're cool
this one's narrow with green Paisley way
yeah I got this one at Nordstrom which
is North's room rack which is I was just
sitting there and thought it was cool
and I have a couple hundred of them you
know they don't wear out it's part of
the stick part of the thing is part of
who I know these days they a bow tie a
bow tie does not slip into your soup
it does not flip into your flask they
have a certain charm and it's it's
become a signature and I started doing
it in junior high school we had to be
waiters at the girls that's wedding
banquet so this is field hockey
gymnastics the girls get their award and
send the boys waiting on them and I said
to everybody if we're gonna be waiters
you know it's let's dress the part let's
go for it and my father was very good
with knots showed me how to tie a bow
tie and then went through many years of
wearing straight I most of the time in a
bow tie occasionally but now and
generally abandon a straight time
although I can tie straight tie at least
two different aesthetically pleasing
ways at least 36 knots we should all go
36 knots
discussion another another discussion in
future next question NASA NASA Mars
rover Curiosity recent has a successful
Randy oh no yes what with you you're
obsessed with the curiosity boom and the
glove the Curiosity rover hey Bill Nye
the Science Guy here CEO of the
Planetary Society the world's largest
non-governmental space interest
organization consider joining us with
that said it was big fun to be a new
media rockstar for the last few minutes
I hope you've rejoined it rewind it
play it back Wow turn it up really loud
thanks you guys see you soon